[Applaudissements]
sortir au choix comme je fais des
interviews quand je suis tout seul aux
toilettes non c'est un client sérieux
depuis je suis petit j'ai en stock ouais
je vous jure j'ai entendu dire ça à la
télé en ce moment ouais ouais c'est à
dire que quand je ferme la porte des
toilettes je suis très gênant je suis à
peine rentré et j'ai comme si on pose
une question
non c'est à dire que je m'assieds en
disant oui absolument c'est quoi ces
balades et jeux mais j'ai cette vision
de moi même je peux y aller trois fois
par jour et 3 fois je m'assois et je
réponds à des questions différentes à
chaque fois j'ai une vision de moi à ce
moment là en disant t il ya un truc qui
va pas quand même